therefore my groom welcome to
trigonometry hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster i'm
konstantine kissin and this is a show
for you if you're bored of people
talking on the internet about subjects
they know nothing about at trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts
we're here in a makeshift studio at the
world-famous angel comedy club and our
amazing expert guest this week is the
fantastic Pippa Mangrum who's a former
senior economic advisor to President
George W Bush a renowned author and the
founder of H robotics thermogram welcome
to trigonometry
PIPA so tell us a little bit about your
journey and how you actually ended up
doing what you did being who you are how
are you here well being an economist I
kind of think I sort of snuck in and
nobody noticed one of the greatest
compliments I ever get his people go
you look like an economist you know I
was lucky my my dad was the chief trade
negotiator for the United States under
Kennedy Johnson Nixon and Ford were for
both sides never left and so I grew up
in a household with my dad explaining
you know when your shoes are made the
upper part will be made in one country
in the lower part in another country and
then put together in a third country so
I just was always interested in what was
going on in the world economy and
studied it and somehow ended up working
in the White House being president's
advisor on economic policy that's when
we had Enron WorldCom seven of the nine
largest bankruptcies in American history
in one year and then we had 9/11 that
was very eventful period in my life and
in everybody's life and I don't know my
thing is really just I'm fascinated by
the world economy and the human aspect
on the other economists they just love
to number crunch and do models and these
huge mathematical formula and I'm like
yeah but how are they feeling you know
I'm more interested in and how does the
society respond to what's happening
they've gotten this is gonna sound like
a really trite question but why is it
like working in the White House just
going in every day I mean that must be a
huge thrill you know it is and I'll tell
you what it's interesting my mom studied
with j.r.r tolkien Wow she said medieval
medieval English we have and I was so
struck when I first went to the White
House and I realize when you walk into
the Oval Office
your ego expands so suddenly you're like
holy I'm here and the president is
asking me my advice and you realize
Gollum lives above the door of the Oval
Office and when you walk in there he
jumps on your shoulder and you're
just goes crazy and and it tells you
don't tell him what you think tell him
what he wants to hear and in that moment
I kind of realized oh my god I'm a
hobbit right I want to tell the
president what he needs to hear not what
I think you know not what he would like
to hear but what I think he needs to
hear and actually a lot of people who
work in that environment they don't
really operate that way they'll tell him
what they think he wants to hear so it
must be fascinating over a period of
time you must see people's personalities
completely change totally I had one
chief executive who came into my office
he goes the president's policies are
terrible and he should fire the
Secretary of Treasury and it's all a
disaster and he's like great let's go
over to tell him and as we're walking he
just bombarding me with how bad it is
and we arrived at the Oval Office as he
crosses the door he turns in this
totally obsequious mr. president I am so
delighted to meet because why he
suddenly has revisions that he is going
to be the American ambassador to name
the country I love best that he's gonna
be invited on Air Force One and this is
one of the biggest problems I think for
all leaders but heads of state literally
you know people get obsessed by the
power and the paraphernalia and the my
precious and it's a huge danger for all
leaders and they have to pick people to
be around them who aren't affected by
all that stuff talking about obsession
with power the question that you
probably get more than any what do you
make up Donald Trump at the moment and
what's been happening the economy seems
to be booming under Donald Trump at the
moment is it gone to farming what is
happening well okay so first of all
presidents don't make the economy do
stuff but their policy stance does
matter it sends a signal but a lot of
the things are happening right now I
started well before Donald Trump so like
for example wages went up in China like
five times in the last three or four
years so the China
Manufacturing pictures not very
competitive anymore and in fact the u.s.
is very competitive in comparison so the
job started moving back to the US now he
says you know I did this well actually
it kind of was already in motion and
you're lucky with that on the other hand
it's also true that his policies are
they're helpful for that outcome so
drawing a line between what a president
gets to take credit for I mean basically
all presents are entitled to their luck
and they all claim credit for stuff that
they didn't necessarily actually cause
the other awkward thing I mean awkward
is putting it mildly today a desire by
those who supported him not just to be a
change in Washington but literally to
burn the whole thing to the drain
disrupt it to be a total destroyer
distract of the system right in the
swamp
brainless law burn it down and as he
does this the honest truth is well
there's some element of truth that had
become hugely overgrown it had become
almost inoperable like my first job and
I know it's really awkward and weird to
say my very first job was working for
President Reagan how many degrees did
you have one of the things you realize
from being around that environment is it
matters how it's structured so at that
time the National Security Council had
like literally 50 people today after
President Obama was in power
it was 450 people now there's not enough
time in the day for 450 people on one
area and national security that doesn't
include the
Kannamma counsel that I was in LAN or
the Domestic Policy Council or homeland
defense to all briefed the president so
you know I'm kind of when that sounds so
terrible though I've got a with Trump on
the you have to make it smaller because
it doesn't work but it still needs to
work somewhat and he's like well I don't
really care whether it works or not I
just want to out of the way the other
thing is you know the way he talks is so
toxic and I think there are a lot of
people who might be aligned with him
philosophically make government smaller
and have lower taxes more freedom for
businesses but we have to insult every
possible member of the community that
doesn't look exactly like a middle-aged
white male yeah see you're troubled by
this oh yeah absolutely it's unnecessary
no but isn't that how he won though it
is well and I would say there's a
negotiating style also reflects us right
so you know we hear not just stuff like
the steel tariffs or he announces you
know we're gonna use the entire nuclear
arsenal on North Korea and everybody
goes to come to the negotiating table I
suspect what we'll find on the threat of
trade wars as everybody comes to the
table so he's like the bully at school
who comes up to on the playground and
first he just wax you gonna just punch
to the chin and when you're lying on the
ground you're like totally off-balance
then he goes okay let's talk it's
literally a style sorry you example and
so anyway highly disruptive and this is
the way to think about he's literally
like an uber phenomena in politics he is
disintermediating the traditional power
structures for better and for worse
depends on your angle do you think yeah
I mean this is quite a loaded question
do you think that he's do you because he
said certain things that can be
construed as race
for instance some Mexicans are racist
right yeah but do you think that is a
tactic of his or do you think he
genuinely believes those sentiments I
don't know him
I've been looking up a number of I say
you're gonna say I mean lucky I haven't
met him my suspicion is that he has this
kind of banter that's deliberately
designed to be totally provocative it's
it's back to the negotiating style but
that probably if you really sat down
with him he is it is not you know
thinking I want to specifically exclude
these minorities from having a future
but how do you disentangle it this is
the question how do you disentangle it
and here's an awkward point here well
when we look at the numbers voters who
supported Trump in the election the
numbers of women and minorities both
African Americans and Hispanics that
supported him was higher than any of the
pollsters appreciate you anticipated
well higher than Mitt Romney and John
McCain actually answer the question why
my theory is this in the establishment
world there's often not a place for
women I mean I left and got some
thinking because I felt I could create
my own thing and have more freedom and
say what I felt about the world and not
be constrained so as a woman I left the
establishment created my own company a
lot of African Americans do the same a
lot Hispanics do the same because their
opportunity for promotion is not huge
right which is something we have to fix
but in the meantime what do you do you
become an entrepreneur now the moment
you're an entrepreneur you're the
breadwinner you got to pay the bills and
you look at Trump and you go I don't
like what he says but if he stands for
lower taxes smaller government less
regulation I'm gonna vote with my Brent
winter hat first and then we can talk
about the position I
you pie in the society which doesn't in
any way forgive this whole business of
being as you say racist and almost
separatist like everyone is in a
separate group with him
it doesn't forgive that but it maybe
explains some of these voting dynamics I
find it incredibly fascinating because
my mother is not an American she's from
Venezuela and she's a fan of Trump and
because the the reason is if she saw a
bomber as being a soft touch and she
likes the fact that there's a present
who was coming who his hardline
who says what he believes in inverted
commas and it's something that she can
you know whether you like him or whether
you don't
you know what Trump stands for and in a
lot of the time with a lot of
politicians especially in the UK you
look at and you go I don't know what you
represent well I hear you and I think
it's very interesting that international
observers are more afraid of Trump than
they've been afraid of previous
presidents and it's a stark contrast
with President Obama for example when I
talk to the Chinese and the Russian
leadership their view was they could
pretty much do anything and get no
reaction from President Obama you know
South China Sea interview right where
the Chinese of building you know all
these sort of military facilities in the
middle of the South Pacific and they
interviewed the general who was in
charge and he said well you know we put
a huge building crane on the island and
we waited for President Obama to react
and then no reaction so then we started
using it and then no reaction we sort of
building a runway no reaction next thing
we're like landing our military jets
there are no reaction that causes them
to think okay well we can do a whole
bunch of things and and basically
there's no consequences then Trump comes
sanity basically you know threatens to
use everything and suddenly everybody
on eggshells and so it's it's a strange
turn around and interestingly the
Chinese in particular view Trump as a
one-off in history and that he is our
first president who was literally
prepared to give away territory so while
he's supposedly tough he's a negotiator
so it means basically a property guy
here he's already got a deal done so for
example with North Korea I suspect the
part of the way he's managed to get
everybody to the negotiating table is
he's basically said to the Chinese if
you can diminish this North Korean
nuclear problem just keep North Korea
just just soft annex that thing and that
is the message he gave the Russians on
Ukraine Frankie said Bo we're not
interested we don't have a national
strategic interest if you want it you
can have it it's the same thing you said
about Syria to the Russians you know you
want it that's a problem we don't want
it and the Chinese are like oh my god
he's giving away territory what can we
get and from a Chinese point of view to
get a greater degree of influence over
North Korea it's a huge benefit to them
so I was saying it's very interesting
that we have a president who is who has
said I'm not into foreign policy and yet
he seems to be presiding over more
movement and foreign policy than we've
seen in many years
it's all very paradoxical
we've talked about Trump let's keep it
like this move on to BRICS essentially
what is BRICS it and if you could just
explain and does it make it racist if
you vote for breaks it okay I think what
it's really about is centralization
versus decentralization of power and all
over the world people have been damaged
by the huge debt burden that's bearing
down I kind of think it's the debt
burden that's like the huge silent
wrecking ball that bears down on the
society and it literally breaks the
promises that hold the society together
so suddenly you realized that government
used to say you could retire in you know
65 and now the messages it's gonna be
like 93 you used to get your trash
picked up by tour no twice a week and
now it's like once a month and if you
have to pay for it if you want more all
these little things cause people to
start getting angry and upset and
they're like hey what has happened here
and then it got worse when we had the
financial crisis and suddenly everybody
who was rich and powerful got a blank
check for having messed up right and
everybody else had to pay for it so so
the first question that comes up is how
does this happened and then the next
question is why aren't you in charge now
the moment you ask them why are you in
charge this is the origin of brexit but
frankly Trump populism in general it's
also the question behind the move to the
right that we're seeing across the
European Union China has had its version
as well of people challenging the
government saying why are you in charge
what are you doing oh really yeah
definitely it doesn't get as much air
time but it's been a very big issue
partly why we've seen a tightening of
the control of power by Xi Jinping so
that's actually a response it was
supposed to change is coming in and go
I want to do the Russian style lifetime
in my view it's absolutely responding
the same set of forces so they're all
global in nature so I don't actually
think that it was a racist impetus
behind it it's more that if the finances
don't add up and you can't you and the
government can't look after me then what
are we gonna do with all these other
people coming in and it's a kind of
demand and request for decision making
to not be made so far away but to come
back to people I've elected people that
I have a connection with and I think
that's at the core of it to be honest
and it won't end until we get the
finances sorted so as long as the
problem is there we can expect populism
to persist and what I find is people
keep thinking that if we elect a one
politician like president macron in
France that he can somehow like wish it
all away and make it better but until
you sort the finances problem then the
problem is economies can't grow fast
enough to deliver on people's
aspirations for the future and that
makes them frustrated with politicians
and they go okay if you can't fix this I
Chuck you out until we bring in somebody
who can and you get ever more radical
results do you think the conservative
policy of austerity indirectly led to
brexit or do you think that was not
really connected you know what I think
across the board we're experiencing now
this is a very technical economic term
that I'm about to use it arises when you
know people really well it's when they
feel and I'm serious about this they
feel castration castration castration
castration so that is when you look at
your bank account and you realize that
more than 50% of your income is needed
to cover your rent or your mortgage and
that is before your groceries and
anything else and at that point you just
are so upset and and
you are like well I want something to
change and I think this is again if you
really want to know what's behind
populism it's not any specific policy
decision it's the inability to get the
public past their castration feeling
well what about the cultural side of a
paper because I'm an immigrant here in
the UK
I talk about being Russian to my sister
Frances everyone involved in this
podcast and in this show is an immigrant
I will always Paul in this country but
my question is this narrative in the
run-up to brexit and since brexit has
been the British people of these
monstrous racist xenophobes which I
really haven't found to be my personal
experiences now in this country so my
curiosity about that is do you think the
narrative in the run-up in the last 15
years there has been this narrative in
politics this idea that if you bring up
the issue of immigration if you're
concerned about large numbers of people
coming to this country from Poland and
from other countries particularly when
under Blair's government there was no
would you call it the period where the
adjustment period when the countries
joined all the other countries put
restrictions on immigration in the
European Union but Britain didn't so
that kind of forced everybody who wanted
to leave their country Poland or others
to come to Britain right there was a
period of a large inflow and at that
time there was this notion that anyone
who brings up the issue of immigration
must be racist do you think that is
something that pushed a lot of people
into the arms of you keep into the arms
of the brexit is I also haven't really
come across this racist element Oh at
the time that brexit was unfolding I had
my book at my book signals and I was up
in the north and talking to people about
how they felt and what they kept saying
was I have no problem with immigrants
I've had immigrants in my community from
all my life my parents life ever since
Empire
my problem is immigrants getting a check
for a new car and I live here and I
don't get a check for a new car in other
words they were they were
aggravated about what the British call
queuing that somehow the outsiders were
jumping the line and getting an
advantage I think that was more the
issue but I actually think this whole
discussion about immigration is a bit of
a red herring it's a much bigger issue
what it is is a breakdown of trust in
institutions across the board right so
we've had you know the media and Trust
in the media has broken down the church
trust in the churches burned down yeah
trust in literally every institution of
society and and as that trust breaks
then people become more closed in in
their thought process immigration is a
becomes an element of that in other
words I don't know that it's a cause I
think it's a response the other thing
too is we talk about inequality and
everything so this is a really huge
problem I think actually there's a
slightly different problem that's much
more serious and and I say what it is is
the elevators are broken and by that
what I mean is it you can handle
inequality in a society if the elevators
work that is to say if people who are up
at the top if they screw up they should
come down but what we do now is we write
a big check and bail them out so they
get to stay they get to continue to own
all the assets even though they messed
up yeah and the people at the bottom the
immigrants who don't have the
connections the education yeah the doors
of opportunity are closed to them and
that this is a serious problem because
the inequality people could live with
that if they knew that we had a fluid
ability that you couldn't make it if you
worked really hard if you were bright if
you put your elbow grease in and that
there would be consequences if you
messed up but all that is frozen now so
I talk to a lot of cheap executives and
they complain about populism and I'm
always like okay so when is the last
time you hired someone who didn't have a
university degree or who came from a
displaced background in some way and
they're like oh I don't hire any of
those people and I'm like bully you know
you hold the doors of opportunity and if
you hold them shut to those people you
can't be surprised the populism results
and by the way the public is gonna push
you out of the way if you don't open
the doors of opportunity so that's why I
think the immigration question we can
focus on it but it's part of a much
bigger problem and let's face it in
Western Europe
we've got aging demographics you know
all innovation benefits from diversity
of thought from new energy younger
people so you know immigration
absolutely is working in our favor
the question is how do you manage the
movement of people and I think that's
another thing is to expect immigrants to
show up in an entirely new society
entirely new culture and that they
should just fit in right away and let go
get a job yeah this takes some education
on the part of the the locals how do you
integrate I mean heck in our militaries
we're not integrating the former
military guys into society right we have
a lot of vets who are not employed this
is insane right that we can't even
integrate people who've come from our
society and gone off and fought our Wars
so I think there's something about how
do we create structures that are more
inclusive more generally and so that's
why I don't know I just don't think
immigration by itself is the either the
question or the answer thank you I was
gonna say do you envisage brexit
becoming a success or do you think it is
going to be this financial disaster as
it's painted in some of the more
left-wing press I think it's paint a
disaster in all the press the only one
who is saying actually the country is
gonna be fine you know my personal view
is Britain would have been fine either
way it's just easier to have the economy
grow more strongly out and I'll explain
why but it's not like it's a binary
win-lose and also it's not a case that
it's either Britain as successful or the
European yin both of them can be
successful I mean the world economy is
full of many economies that are all
successful in their own different ways
so what really bugs me is this idea that
the British economy is gonna slide into
the North Sea and just
like this is not what happens to the
fifth largest economy in the world so
here's how I think about it the
decisions been made so money is a lot
like water
it literally flows to wherever it faces
the least resistance so unless the
British are gonna raise their taxes and
their regulatory red tape to be at or
above the EU levels which personally I
think is an impossible task the bridge
couldn't do it even if they want to do
so and also if they were to abandon the
traditional British rule of law and be
comfortable moving to the Napoleonic
Code environment that dominates the
cotton continent yeah then maybe but the
fact is that's not where the British are
and so I think actually the economy is
turning out to be just fine and we can
see the data is all better right
employment is higher unemployment is
lower growth has gone up but we haven't
left yet well I know but you know what
markets discount all that in advance so
this idea that somehow we just haven't
hit that wall yet doesn't really work
for me and I'm working with the world's
biggest investors right I'm talking to
the biggest institutional investor
sovereign wealth funds at Petra but
here's what they say they say I may not
like the uncertainty of brexit but I
still can't make any money in Italy in
France in Germany because the economies
are too slow they're not growing fast
enough they're not dynamic enough you
don't have enough innovation going on
you still have you know in in Italy
nearly 40% unemployment of people aged
25 and under which is why they're all in
the UK because there's nothing for them
to do at home so all that innovation
came here so they're all saying you know
I'm gonna continue to deploy foreign
direct investment into the UK even
though brags that has happened so my
hope is that what happens in the EU is
they move more in the British direction
which is to free up and to have less
regulatory red tape less sort of
top-down state control but I fear
they're moving in the other direction
and that's something people haven't
talked about yet is you know the new EU
without Britain may be much more
centralizing
more centralizing power than before and
I think this is partly why we're seeing
the voters say no and so you see the
rise of the right voters the right wing
voters in Italy in Germany in Denmark
and Sweden in Austria
what is this coming from the blue no
it's coming because the more they you
try to tighten and centralize and
top-down control the more the public
says well actually I'd rather have the
decisions made at the level of my
government where I know so in a sense
they're having their own brexit
phenomena it may not end in anybody
leaving but it's the same set of
questions it's the exact same set of
questions but I find that fascinating
because my father voted for Bracy my
dad's not racist he married an immigrant
and and I remember talking to him about
ye voting he went because Europe want a
Federal Republic of Europe and I don't
want that you know I love going to
Europe I love think but I'm not I don't
want that well I think this is the key
thing I love Europe
I've lived in France for many years I
have great admiration for everything
that all the European ideals etc I think
there's a question about the
philosophical direction that the
leadership of the Commission has taken
and they are moving in a much more as
you say Federalists you know and the
first speeches after brexit we're gonna
one european army one european you know
policy stance and you know countries
like Ireland they're like wait does that
mean we have to raise our tax rates to
be the same as the rest of Europe and
the answer's yes that's what they want
to have happen and it's so if you
believe there should be competition
between these nations to see who can be
most competitive then you're not really
comfortable with where the European
Union is going but that doesn't mean you
don't love Europe or you don't admire
the ideals of a unified Europe the
question is what is the right direction
and the voters in Europe are gonna
express themselves and we're seeing that
so that's totally their called where
they want to go with that because it's
fascinating how I mean because working
in comedy in the comedy industry it's
incredibly left-wing and a number of
people I mean I voted remain but a lot
of people were saying well we should
have another referendum and that to me
is undemocratic do you agree with that
or do you think we should absolutely
stand by the referendum yeah I find it
you know hard to imagine going to
another referendum I don't see I don't
see how it would make things better and
I could see how it makes things worse my
big question is why they threw it out on
the table to begin with you know and I
don't think enough people kind of go
back and ask David Cameron what were you
thinking what was that about exactly and
it's a good example of politicians who
assumed they just assumed and actually
the public's in a different place from
what they assumed and this is part I
think he thought he was gonna win and
everybody working in office was like we
were completely shocked totally shocked
have you been outside of London at all
you know all you have to do is get
outside of London and you hear it right
away
you know it's a question of perspective
I think that's one of the problems I've
just I'm just finishing a book on
leadership leadership in the 21st
century and and one of the things that's
interesting is we move so fluidly right
we get on a plane we go to China we're
in the United States so we go oh I know
what's happening but just because you go
somewhere doesn't mean you know what is
happening and I think that's one thing
we've all got to be better at is to not
just go and assume but to go and listen
and you'll hear people tell you things
that won't be consistent with what you
thought well it's fascinating and we'll
make this the final point on brexit he's
fascinating to me because the reason
we're doing the show is that for us I
think brexit and trumpet there were
massive wake-up calls I can certainly
speak for myself it was it was like I
knew what was the truth and then
suddenly the next day wasn't true
anymore we and I realized in how much of
an eco chamber
we've been living and that's why we
really want to talk to different people
who have different ideas and different
input on these issues because I feel
like if you just go online for your news
like we have been doing you are really
not getting a full picture at all no not
at all
so this
the reason I started to write my book
signals because I feel like what what
happens is it's literally like
everybody's going through life blind in
one eye
because they'll only look through a
mathematical lens at data and models
this deep almost religious belief that
all the answers are things that can be
quantified and all of the models missed
what has happened and I'm like okay so
why we opened the other eye that just
looks at all the common-sense things
right in front of you and begins to
detect you know how much pain are people
feeling I mean show me a metric that
measures the amount of pain people are
feeling but if your rent is going up and
your job security is going down you're
gonna feel pain so I'm very big on
reintroducing into the study of
economics the discussion of economics
the qualitative factors which should
weigh just as much and count for just as
much as the quantitative factors but
it's a really hard argument because
everybody in economics is like these
quantum ass guys and they want to all
argue about the numbers and at point
zero four and you're like but the person
is crying you're clearly in pain about
their situation how do you put that in
the model
so rush has been in the news as you know
I'm from Russia and obviously by the
time this podcast goes out we could be
in the safe World War 3 we could all be
dead who knows right but Russia has been
in the news and just looking at the
broad picture of what's been happening
visa vie Russia and the West what is
going on so first thing is there's such
a disparity in the way Russia is viewed
so for example the Russians were said in
recent years that they want to establish
a permanent naval presence in the
Mediterranean right right and that's
connected to their presence in Syria and
the view you get from the Americans you
know the Pentagon guys is well do you
think their ships will sink on the way
or on the way back tiny rinky-dinky
little country that happens to have
nuclear weapons and Russia's view is we
are super power and the fact their
economy is not functioning very well is
by the by we are a nuclear superpower so
it creates this disparity and a
perception gap I'm sorry I appreciate
you not doing a Russian accent there by
the way there's this tendency to view
Russia as a small player not really very
significant I think also means that we
missed some materially important events
like we're seeing something that the
deputy head of NATO called the arc of
Steel which is the Russians are building
physical military bases through the
Arctic they're becoming much more
confrontational and aggressive in the
Baltics Lithuanian Sweden have
reintroduced conscription they're so
nervous about what's happening and all
the way through down into the
Mediterranean we see the first Russian
military exercises in Libya in Egypt
places that we don't normally think of
Russians being present so there's
definitely something up right
geopolitics is definitely back on the
landscape the peace dividend has
diminished right and there's no question
we're still in
nuclear world and one of the things I
find interesting is younger people who
have no memory of the Cold War and
mutual assured destruction they don't
take this very seriously they're like
don't be ridiculous nobody's actually
gonna use these things and I'm like you
know I remember because my dad was in
charge of the missile trajectories
during the Cuban Missile Crisis and at
one point we were down to about four
hours and that was the window and they
literally started preparing on both
sides to evacuate for a direct nuclear
hit and interestingly that's the moment
when it all stopped because everybody in
government went can I take my at that
time wife and children right because all
guys and charge me and and they all went
well I'm not going if I can't take my
family and as soon as they reach that
point they all went okay let's get this
thing to stand down which I think itself
is fascinating but today what do we have
we have hypersonic weapons
I mean you won't have four hours right
this is a totally different world with
much faster speed and so I think it is
important we need to take this these
nuclear issues seriously and I think
that this is partly what makes the
discussion so difficult because from a
Russian point of view everything is
about them as a nuclear power and for
the American side everything is about
Russia being a rinky-dinky tiny little
nothing of an economy and this is an
impasse that they cannot get past and
the Russians try to demonstrate their
power in other ways we've seen some of
that lately and I think they will
continue to so and interestingly you
know in this new book I'm writing on
leadership I wanted to use the phrase
the new Cold War and my editor said well
we're really kind of uncomfortable with
that and you're like well what do we
call it and you realize we don't really
have a word or phrase for this new phase
that we're in and it's partly
collaborative it's partly
confrontational it's not just between
the west and Russia it's also between
the US and China we're having actual
military incidents I mean we under Obama
we had this unbelievable moment where
Obama and Xi Jinping actually
signed a Memorandum of Understanding
that prohibits the military pilots on
both sides from making obscene hand
gestures while flying okay wait how
close do you have to be to the other
fighter jet to see the other guys
obscene hand gesture and the answer is
like two coats of paint and that's how
close we flying next to each other
giving each other the finger it was not
made up this is for real so we're in a
band very very important time in
geopolitics and I don't think we have
enough people really focused on it
because it was not a topic for the last
Deborah since the Berlin Wall fell it
went away as a subject so I mean how
risk are we of war at the moment so I
don't think we're at risk of war however
I would say we used to talk about the
European theater of war and the Pacific
Theater right in World War two these
euphemisms today the theater has moved
offstage where are the confrontations
occurring they're typically occurring in
places the public and the media can't
see so the race for high altitude
military satellites and who can knock
out the other guys military satellites
at high altitude it's occurring in
places like the South China Sea that are
out of the visibility of the COS
extraterritorial locations it's
occurring in the form of a technology
race right President Putin recently said
artificial intelligence is the new space
race and he's right about that
so this race that actually the public
doesn't really understand is occurring
and it's huge the Chinese have just
announced they're building it's
incredible this four million square foot
facility and on high it will have when
they're done it'll be the world's
largest quantum computer which is what
you need for artificial intelligence and
it will literally have 100 million times
no I'm sorry
1 million times the computational
capability of the entire planet today
when it's finished in three years so
when you say
you like that guy from Austin Powers
there but here's keeping our we in a war
we have to change what is our definition
of war because I don't think we're gonna
be in a world where it's the kind of
boots on the ground that we've been
accustomed to but it can be equally
important what is occurring now in the
high-tech arena so you working your
businesses in this area isn't it and one
of the things that's scary as hell about
all this stuff is there's technology now
that they can basically switch off the
brakes in your car is there some course
absolutely there's stuff that can just
give you a heart attack and no one can
tell why you had one we have innovation
happening on every possible front and
we're more and more entering what I
would call them a new dimension of
reality okay now you're gonna think
she's lost her we have ubiquitous
sensors cameras the signature on your
cell phone the RFID chips and the seams
of your clothes I mean everyone does
chips in this yeah seems low voice yeah
and they're literally 1/3 of the size of
the dimple of a golf ball so even if you
wanted to rip them all out you'll never
find out I'm officially triggered okay
and what's happening is all this data
goes up into the cloud which nobody
understands the cloud now that works
right and artificial intelligence
triangulates and it connects the dots
and it creates almost like a holographic
data spear so that you can see reality
with far more precision than if you are
looking at reality with your own eyes
she knows something paper there is one
guy watching this on the internet who
smokes a lot we used to talk about black
boxes data-driven black box yeah this is
literally like almost a crystal ball
because it has so much information so
for example imagine that you guys have
no fitness apps course we do have
moment you don't have any fitness apps
your phone is still tracking the gait of
your walk the way you walk and
apparently Apple can literally tell who
is about to have a heart attack because
the way you walk changes now that
information is you know going up or
here's another one there's a guy some
guy literally burned his house down
right he poured the gasoline petrol all
over all over the place and then he said
I wasn't there I was at this other
location
what he totally forgot is that he has a
pacemaker that's broadcasting not only
his physical location but the fact that
his heart rate has gone through the roof
while he's pouring the petrol around so
we have to forget all of us are being
were broadcasting all the time
even when we don't realize it and this
will happen more and more with
technological innovation now on the one
hand it brings good things because you
can answer questions and you can solve
cancer you can fix problems you can make
traffic in urban areas more fluid and
free but it also brings this problem of
societal control and it's a two-edged
short and I think this is the big
economic issue that we're all walking
into that we need to think about what
we're running out of time and we've got
one way sure that we want to cover but
this has rapidly become the most
depressing podcast to go by so there is
literally trekkers in our clothes yes
absolutely and just every type of Club
so you go tonight there'll be trackers
you'll go to absolutely and you're in
your sneakers and then your wallet and
literally every out of your glasses
there's a company now that's putting
trackers in eyeglasses yeah I was
talking to the head of a clothing
company recently and he's like I know
which of my customers goes to synagogue
on Sunday I know who goes to church Sons
on sorry City going on Saturday church
on Sunday I know who likes which bar
because you can see where they go they
put on their best clothes so yeah this
idea that we're constantly being tracked
and broadcast this is a real phenomena
we're way beyond privacy but let me
finish my donut beat now look at my ears
I know
that people haven't really clocked this
it's it's it's it's the whole point of
all these sensors that are going in
everywhere hotel rooms right now they're
putting the sensors in the floor so they
can actually see how you use the hotel
room space and I'm like this must be
hilarious when I go to hotel room
because the first thing I do is I want
to plug my computer in and where do they
put the plug they put it like under the
desk so the first thing I do is I get
down on my hands and knees on the floor
that's just got to give the wrong
impression about what she's doing with
everything literally the walls
everything a lot of office buildings now
they've got cameras in the walls that
are tracking how you use the space
during the day so anyway I don't listen
let me get to the good part all right
the good part is we really are in an in
an extraordinary industrial revolution
the magnitude of innovation that's
occurring is truly epic it's so much
people can't even comprehend and I'm
very optimistic about this and the
betterment of society
I actually think also that the stock
markets and asset prices are not gonna
crash every economist is like it's
imminent doom gloom it's tomorrow I
think quite the opposite
whatever the old all-time high was it's
now much higher and for two reasons one
because this incredible innovation and
the cost savings and I know you know I
have a robotics company we make
commercial drone so I can see just that
alone the cost savings and the better
management of environmental issues oh
that's good stuff but in addition you
know where everybody remembers this with
this awkward phrase quantitative easing
right what that was is we threw 20
trillion dollars at the world economy
and governments have not taken it back
right they've said well we'll do a
couple of rate hikes but it's like
taking a cup of water out of the
Atlantic Ocean right they are not taking
twenty trillion off the table so it's
still there
and that means it's got to go somewhere
and now we're getting a tiny bit of
inflation which everybody is feeling
right because the cost of the beer you
know down the pubs going up right so
you're like that means I got to get out
of cash
because you get killed if you're holding
cash with inflation so what does
everybody do they start to buy equities
they start to invest in the economy they
buy property so I actually think the
risk is that we're gonna have what they
call melt up not a meltdown everybody's
waiting for this huge meltdown disaster
on a scale of what the 2008 crisis was
like I think the bigger risk is that
we're all going oh my god it's gonna
crash it's a disaster and in fact what's
in front of us is an amazing landscape
and this pessimism is wrongly placed
well there's one other issue that we
want to talk about and actually I mean
the stuff you were just talking about
there
if you ever happy enough to come back I
think we could talk about robotics of
that for a whole hour
there's been a lot in the media and also
with it obviously with a me-too movement
as well about the gender pay gap for
instance so if you could clarify for us
what the gender pay gap is and does it
exist
and if it does exist why does it exist
well the gender pay gap is basically you
pay someone because they're female
typically less than you pay someone
who's male I think it extends actually
beyond gender you might be paying people
of minority backgrounds less than your
we're paying some guy who's been doing
it so I think it's part of again this
bigger issue of of distrust in authority
in authority and questioning how why are
the rules like this how come this works
this way I mean a couple of years ago I
do a lot of public speaking and
literally two or three years ago I had a
public speaking agency say to me we
can't get you the same price as your
male peers even though you're getting
higher scores with audiences and it's
because you're female and I'm like well
then you and I cannot work together
anymore so you're not representing me
anymore
there's anybody who thinks this is crazy
now on the other hand do I have to did I
have to change in order to get my my
fees up and to get paid what the guys
get paid yes I did and that meant I had
to be a lot tougher and it was something
as a as a woman I might not have been so
comfortable with but you know if you
will really want to get to the top it's
a competitive space and you got to punch
your way there to a degree so some of it
and you know it's hard to attribute
what's the cause what's the bottom line
is very few people are willing to accept
it anymore and I think we're seeing good
signs that that it's gonna go away like
Blackstone which is the world's largest
asset manager they came out and said any
company that doesn't have at least two
women on the board we're not going to
invest in them and suddenly everybody's
like oh okay well then we better do this
but one issue I have as well as you know
as a person who gets recruited to be a
non-executive director quite a lot
sometimes I feel like you know they
really want and this is gonna be so
controversial I probably good thing but
they're like what they really want is a
man in a dress in other words they want
to say see we got a woman but do
I really want you to bring all of the
things that you might bring which might
be a focus on things that are not so you
know P&L right as a woman I might say
well you know empathy might be a
corporate consideration that or I might
say okay chief executives totally
focused on the the company being
profitable yeah but we our social media
position is terrible and we could lose
the reputation of this company in an
hour on social media if we don't pay
attention to that that might be seen by
some people as a very feminine approach
you know focusing on the soft stuff my
view is actually all people who are in
leadership or who want to be they need
to play the whole keyboard you there are
times when this more masculine way of
thinking is appropriate even for a woman
there are times when a more feminine way
of thinking is more appropriate even for
a man and what you want is to know how
to fluidly move back and forth and in
the right moment in order to achieve the
right outcome but the old-fashioned kind
of binary as long as we're profitable
everything is good yeah that doesn't
really work anymore and adding women to
your board if that's your attitude this
doesn't change anything so you don't
benefit from any diversity so I guess
what I'm saying is it's what matters is
the diversity of thinking and that
doesn't get fixed only by having women
it gets fixed by having people of
totally different backgrounds completely
different angles different life
experiences different genders different
races different cultures if you mix all
that up now we're talking mm-hmm so
would you be in favor of positive
discrimination I'm not in favor I I
don't think it works too forcefully
mandate so for example the difference
between what the Norwegians have done
where they say by law every company has
to have certain number women on the
board I think the in Iceland they've
said it has to be more than 50% I think
it works better when Blackstone says
we're not investing unless you have at
least a couple in other words the market
starts to take care of it itself and I
have to say I still absolutely believe
in meritocracy so I think people should
be put in place because
they're meritorious what's wrong is to
take people who have merit and close the
doors of opportunity to them and that is
happening still way too much I mean we
still get crazy outcomes I think this
last year somebody reviewed the intake
of new graduates coming into Oxford
University and they discovered there
wasn't a single British black kid
admitted and then in the year I mean
that's just crazy that doesn't make any
sense so I don't know how we resolved
this but what I am confident about is
everybody gets it now and so it won't I
won't go it won't just fade away
it'll get addressed well I think that's
we're coming to the end of the podcast
well the show I think it's been
absolutely fascinating thank you so much
and before we let you go is there
anything that you think no one is
talking about that we absolutely should
be talking about you know the thing that
I feel is most important is this
business about robotics and everybody
fearing that robots gonna replace me and
my life and and I don't see that at all
I mean let's think about it this way
we've had a hundred and fifty years of
automation and more robotics being
introduced and what is the end result
record level employment record level
employment
so what robotics and automation do is
they augment human beings and yes they
will replace some of the jobs frankly
what the jobs are gonna replace are the
ones that are really repetitive
incredibly boring so if you are an
accountant doing repetitive work or a
lawyer doing repetitive work yes you've
got a problem but these people are
together enough they can figure out how
to go reinvent themselves and find
something new and interesting to do what
it'll do is force us all to become much
more creative and build new businesses
new ideas come up with entirely new
sectors in the economy and we do this
all the time I mean if you'd ask anybody
four years ago they would never have
thought of marijuana as an entire sector
of an economy they would never have
thought of blockchain as an entire
second but here we are it exists you
know 20 years ago who had ever really
heard of a coder nobody so it
always innovate and so I'm very
confident that actually we will continue
to have fantastic levels of employment
and innovation and robotics will work
with us to that end so I just think a
little bit of optimism on that front you
know again why are we all preparing for
a car crash when in fact we're about to
have the best assistance we've ever had
in history well I think that's the most
amazing way to end a show thank you for
coming in and PIPA thank you before we
go that you would like to tell the
audience about whether it's your Twitter
handle or your books or whatever else
sure yes twitter handle is dr. Pippa M
and that was deliberate because I wanted
to put Pippa M because nobody can
pronounce Mellon grin you know too many
constants but Pippa em you get
photographs of Pippa Middleton's
rear-end yeah which well though it's a
good look to be associated with this is
not the wine I was after so I had to put
the doctor in front anyway dr. Pippa M
and I try to put stuff up all the time
about what's going on in the world
economy and I have a book called signals
that's out the paperback version is the
most up-to-date and that kind of
explains populism and how we got here
and how we're gonna go forward with a
very optimistic take and I have a book
on leadership coming out on September
4th we'll be getting that thank you very
much for coming in pip I think thank you